quand on arrive en france
ouah la vie est belle salut c'est
vincent de la chaîne partager c'est
sympa aujourd'hui je suis avec baptiste
de bataille à elle et on est dans la
vallée de briançon on va aller à
montgenèvre située à 1800 mètres
d'altitude où chaque jour et chaque nuit
des migrants exil est temps de passer la
frontière entre la france et l'italie
[Musique]
m
alors bienvenue un station de ski de
montgenèvre un peu plus loin par là bas
c'est l'italie et si on est sur cette
station ski c'est que c'est du point de
passage puisque empruntent les migrants
pour essayer de rejoindre la france et
avoir le droit de déposer leur demande
d'asile en france on a la chance
accompagné d'arnaud moi je suis je suis
partie de l'association tous milandes et
depuis 2016 en maraude dans ces
montagnes pour venir pour venir en aide
aux personnes qui tentent de passer qui
finissent d'ailleurs généralement pas
repasser pour qu'ils arrivent aussi pour
arriver à se couvrir les gens le plus
discrètement possible pour qu'elle soit
pas reconduite à la frontière à manu
militari qu'elle ne soit pas maltraité
par la police aux frontières
[Musique]
de nombreux témoignages qui montrent
qu'il ya des violences physiques ça des
vols la l'intimidation
alors outre des coûts les menaces de
mort il risque deux mois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
ce qui est souvent risquerait pas
d'aller de nuit dans la montagne je perd
tout sens de l'orientation américain tu
connais pas un peu le terrain que tu pas
un peu aguerris au sens de l'orientation
en montagne de savoir te repérer au
casse pipe
je vais pas si longtemps il ya un jeune
qui est mort jeune togolais et amis non
28 ans qui est mort sur le bord de la
route après avoir été dépeint par ses
collègues de misère et qui est mort de
froid qui peut terminer
[Musique]
en théorie rien puisque c'est 100% la
gamme jeu lorsque je fais c'est
l'humanitaire sade au secours de gens
qui sont en détresse dans la montagne
sans passer la frontière
c'est 100% légal et ce qui est
hallucinant c'est la présence policière
et l'embranchement encore encore ce soir
on est obligé de se cacher de de la
police
[Musique]
finalement se substitue à l'état ça
devrait être à l'état de venir en aide
aux gens qui sont en train de mourir à
quelques pas des maisons pour faire avec
les moyens du bord puisque de toute
façon toute façon il n'y a pas le choix
il faut le faire gsmn
on n'a pas idée de laisser mourir
quelqu'un dans son jardin
[Musique]
arnaud c'est quoi les lumières mais en
face c'est l'italie c'est pas loin pour
nous ses passions de mai en bagnole de
briançon tue quelqu'un qui connaît pas
le chemin qui a peur de la police qui se
cache qui reprend qui reprend la route
vers m la nuit il ya des gens qui
arrivent au pied matin ce qui arrive
quelques heures des balades dans la
montagne
allez vous croisez du monde on les
aurait croisés ce soir ça soit ça sera
bordeaux où il mais bon c'est que partie
remise
aujourd'hui on va à la rencontre
des gens qui s'occupent du refuge là on
va retrouver les personnes qui sont
peut-être arrivé dans la nuit malgré les
jets falcon les ai pas vus donc on voit
qu'on se passe
[Musique]
depuis j'ai donné 17 on est à 7800
personnes qui sont passés par ici
ce genre la moitié de la population
bilan 500 fresco est donc oui ça fait
pas mal de monde nous la particularité
c'est qu'on est juste un lieu de transit
à dire qu'on est un accueil d'urgence
comme un refuge de montagne
[Musique]
moi je suis médecin retraité jean n'a
voulu faire une pré consultation ici
quotidienne à partir d'ici on les
renvoie l'hôpital pour faire des radios
des examens complémentaires des
hospitalisations qui en a besoin
ici à briançon fait rien pour elle mais
au froid ils ont marché des heurts sont
avec des chaussures des tentacules
adapté dans la neige êtes-vous arrivée
celle du jury puis il ya tous les grades
de jeu durand 1er 2e 3e degré et puis un
qui est complètement gelé puisqu'il est
mort il ya quelques semaines mort de
froid c'est ce qu on a du mal à
comprendre que la militarisation du
poste frontière fait qu'ils passent par
des chemins détournés long de la
traversée de désert traversé la mer j'ai
traversé la libye c'est pas quelques
kilomètres de plus ou de moins qui vont
les retenir
et tout le reste a été lavé ok c'est
super de perdre chose que j'ai pas pensé
avant mais j'ai beaucoup de gens ont
encore plein de jeunes paraît normal je
sais qu'il ya des gens qui l'ont revu ce
qui arrive qui ont froid et et ils
viennent de pays chauds en général dont
il s'est acquitté pour autant les aider
que l'on peut été ton parcours avant
d'arriver ici ce que j'ai tenté de
rentrer en verre modane et la police a
contrôlé la frontière ils ont tous
décidé avec mon récit pis c'est tout et
il me fierais toumi encore jusqu'à ax et
quand tu vieillis super du jeu puis de
montagne chez moi
quant à eux arrivés devant la montagne
il faut que ça montait j'allais gable
gps je vois que la france ses délires la
montagne j'étais attends je vais
traverser la montagne après j'ai plus un
montant mais tu avais pas peur à ce
moment là non je suis
sa première fois et
ce qu'on n'ait pas la route j'ai
commencé de campillo montagne à 10
heures 2 heures du matin j'ai fini en un
menteur cd v rex et les acquis qui ont
l'air mottola qui travaillent là bas ses
créanciers qui ont pris moi je ne savais
pas que c'est en france
ah ouais bah oui je suis arrivé ici à
l'hôpital
je suis là parce que je voulais faire
l'apprentissage de mécanique parce que
c'est moi c'était mon rêve quand t'as
pas de papier tu peux pas faire
l'apprentissage c'est ça tu penses tu
vas y ma vie où je pense que je vais
là-bas ouais
les ben dis donc y est intense très
intense dans ce qu'ils vivent et ce
qu'ils ont traversé en fait il pense
être arrivé ce qu'ils ont avoir fait le
plus dur mais il se rend compte que le
plus dur aussi
et là quoi
[Musique]
pour monsieur enchanté baptiste pourquoi
la commune de briançon a décidé de
mettre à disposition de bâtiments des
crs pour les réfugiés pour le refus
solidaire simplement de les aider à
reprendre des forces
et puis à partir parce qu'il est pour
nous si vous voulez briançon n'est pas
un lieu de séjour définitif c'est un
lieu de passage
comment réagissent les habitants de
briançon à la situation actuelle
l'étranger c'est d'abord la peur donc on
a peur qu'il soit différent on a peur
que sa culture vous déborde qu' il est
des attitudes que vous comprenez pas
c'est qu'il faut pas avoir peur il faut
y aller faut aller les rencontrer faut
aller voir faut discuter et puis on
découvre que sont des femmes des hommes
comme les autres
mais l'essentiel c'est quand même la
politique de l'état c'est la politique
de l'europe
c'est ça qui est important et quand je
vois aujourd'hui des députés européens
français et italiens qui viennent nous
voir ce soit ici ou de l'autre côté de
la frontière c'est gentil de venir nous
voir à la veille des élections ne s'est
pas la veille des élections qu'on a
besoin d'eux c'est dans les textes qui
sont en train de préparer de manière à
savoir qu'est ce qu'on fait avec les
migrants qu'est ce qu'on fait avec le
processus migratoire qu'est ce qu'on
fait dans les pays d'origine pour que
les gens qui viennent ici puissent
rester chez eux
c'est ça le problème
[Musique]
mon petit bilan de notre aventure après
avoir rencontré pas mal d'intervenants
comme sont divers secteurs
on se rend un peu compte de la
problématique qui a aujourd'hui à cet
endroit précis de la france on est nul
et c'est tellement que le début parce
que le changement climatique qui va pas
partir les scientifiques sont unanimes
là-dessus les guerres a priori on est
bien pu lui exactement et je sais de
plus en plus de gens au sud qui ne vont
plus pouvoir vivre et je trouve ça
parfaitement légitime pour quelqu'un qui
ne plus plus vives sur cette planète de
vouloir vivre et 10 rebonds tout citoyen
il fait bon je vais là tout ce qui
devrait être fait pour le bon accueil de
ces personnes qui ont risqué leur vie et
qui arrivent dans le pays des droits de
l'homme
quand même le répéter le rappeler
surtout
non non non
on n'est pas du tout le plus beau cadeau
qu'on puisse faire un être humain en
détresse et le reconnaître comme un
autre être humain plutôt que juste la
partie en détresse et c'était fascinant
de voir que dans le langage
administratif c'est de l'immigration
irrégulière et surtout on ne va pas
parler des exploits ils sont là alors
que partout dans le refuge solidaire y
avait écrit amour solidarité partage
entre elle et c'était c'est l'humain qui
était au coeur et je pense c'est
vraiment ça qui fournit
[Musique]